E
TROUBLED, LAURA IS NEXT.
>> Laura: I'M LAURA INGRAHAM
AND THIS IS A FOX NEWS OF
RELIEF.
POLITICAL REPORTING ON A LEAKED
DRAFT OF THE SUPREME COURT
OPINION IN THE MISSISSIPPI
ABORTION CASE.
AND JUST TO SAY MILTON HAS BEEN
ASSIGNED THE MAJORITY OPINION,
WHICH ACCORDING TO THE DRAFT,
MEANS ROE VS. WADE WILL BE
OVERTURNED.
WHAT DOES THIS MEAN?
THIS RETURNS THE APPORTIONMENT
ISSUE TO THE STATES, WHICH
PREROE, WHICH IS WHERE IT WAS
ALWAYS WAS.
SOME WILL ALLOW, SOME SITES
MIGHT BAN IT, SOME WILL FIND
WHAT THEY BELIEVE IS A MIDDLE
GROUND.
I WANT TO SAY THIS VERY CLEARLY
TONIGHT.
NO MATTER WHAT YOU THINK ABOUT
THIS OUTCOME, THE LEAK ITSELF
REPRESENTS A SHOCKING AND
UNPRECEDENTED BREACH OF THE
COURTS CONFIDENTIALITY.
AND IT IS KEY TO THE COURTS
ABILITY, ON ANY ISSUE, TO ENGAGE
AND THEY IN THE GIVE-AND-TAKE
AND ALL THE DECISION-MAKING THAT
IS REQUIRED TO REACH THESE
DECISIONS BASED ON LEGAL
PRINCIPLE.
BASED ON THE CONSTITUTION.
NOT BECAUSE OF POLITICAL
PRESSURE.
THAT IS WHAT THE LEGISLATURE
DOES, NOT THE COURT.
AND THOSE, ESPECIALLY THE LAW
CLERKS, THEY ARE AFFORDED A
TREMENDOUS PRIVILEGE.
THINK ABOUT THAT.
TO WORK AT THE COURT, TO LEARN
FROM THE JUSTICES.
BUT THE INVALUABLE DEAL THAT YOU
STRIKE WHEN YOU ACCEPT THAT
CLERKSHIP, WHICH IS THE MOST
COVETED THING YOU COULD HAVE AS
A YOUNG LAWYER, IS THAT YOU
SWEAR CONFIDENTIALITY REGARDING
EVERYTHING YOU SEE AND
EVERYTHING YOU HEAR.
AND ESPECIALLY THE INTERNAL
DELIBERATIONS OF THE COURT,
ESPECIALLY THAT.
IT IS NOT UP TO A LAW CLERK TO
DECIDE WHEN THE DECISION OF THE
COURT WILL BE ANNOUNCED.
AND IT DOES NOT UP TO A LAW
CLERK OR ANY EMPLOYEE OF THE
COURT TO LEAK A DECISION AND
WHAT IS A NAKED ATTEMPT TO TRY
TO CHANGE THE OUTCOME BEFORE THE
FINAL OPINION IS ISSUED.
NOW WHY AM I SO PASSIONATE ABOUT
THIS TONIGHT?
I ACTUALLY KNOW WHAT I'M TALKING
ABOUT.
A LOT OF PEOPLE ON TELEVISION DO
NOT KNOW WHAT THEY WERE TALKING
ABOUT.
I WAS A SUPREME COURT LAW KIRK.
AND I KNOW, BECAUSE I SAW IT.
DRAFTS IN THE DON'T LIKE
OPINIONS GOING BACK AND FORTH.
LANGUAGE CHANGES.
SOMETIMES, SOMETIMES EVEN VOTES
MIGHT CHANGE.
MAY BE A JUSTICE WILL SEE AN
ARGUMENT HE OR SHE DIDN'T THINK
OF, IT'S RARE, BUT IT DOES
HAPPEN.
THIS IS ALL DONE CONFIDENTIALLY
TO ENCOURAGE THIS FREE EXCHANGE
OF IDEAS THAT IS ALWAYS BEEN --
IT DOESN'T MATTER.
IT IS DEEMED ESSENTIAL TO THE
PROPER FUNCTIONING OF OUR
NATION'S HIGHEST COURT.
CHIEF JUSTICE REHNQUIST, AND OUR
ORIENTATION SESSION AT THE
COURT, SAID TO ALL OF US, SO
THERE'S NINE JUSTICES FOR CLERKS
FOR EACH CHAMBER.
ABOUT 36.
I MET A COUPLE OF THE RETIRED
JUSTICES STILL HAVE CLERKS THAT
ARE STILL AT THE COURT.
BUT NOT MONEY.
IT IS ABOUT 36, 40 YOUNG
LAWYERS.
HE LOOKED AT US AND HE SAID, IF
YOU LEAK ANYTHING FROM THIS
COURT, YOU CAN KISS YOUR LEGAL
CAREER GOODBYE.
DONE.
YES, WE REMEMBER THAT.
THROUGH THE ENTIRETY OF THE
COURT'S HISTORY, NO MATTER HOW
CONTROVERSIAL OR DISRUPTIVE THEY
HAVE BEEN, AND I AM TALKING
DECADES, DECADES OF DECISIONS ON
THE FREEDOM OF RELIGION, RIGHTS
OF CRIMINALS, SAME-SEX MARRIAGE.
NONE OF THOSE DRAFT OPINIONS
EVER LEAKED.
YOU KNOW WHY CUSTOMER BECAUSE
EVERYONE IN THE BUILDING
UNDERSTOOD THAT WAS A LINE THAT
COULD BE NEVER CROSSED.
IT IS A SAD COMMENTARY THAT
SOMEONE IN THAT BUILDING TOOK IT
UPON HIMSELF OR HERSELF TO
TOTALLY USURP THE ROLE OF THE
JUSTICES AND HIJACK THE COURT'S
DELIBERATIVE PROCESS.
THIS WAS A BALD-FACED ATTEMPT TO
TIP THE BALANCE OF THE VOTE ONE
WAY OR ANOTHER.
WE KNOW WHICH WAY.
THE LEAKER UNDOUBTABLY HOPES,
RIGHTS, THAT THIS LEAKED OPINION
WILL DRIVE ACTIVISTS TO THE
COURT DOORS.
THEY WERE DESPERATELY BANGING ON
THE DOORS DURING
BRETT KAVANAUGH'S CONFIRMATION
HEARING.
ALL OF THEM OUTSIDE SCREAMING,
ALL THE COLORFUL SIDES.
THAT'S GOING TO HAVE SOME IMPACT
THAT WILL HAVE ONE OF THE
JUSTICES, THE MAJORITY, CHANGE
HIS OR HER VOTE.
ONCE AGAIN, IT LOOKS LIKE THE
LEFT WILL JUST SMASH AN
ESTABLISHED GOVERNMENT PROCESS
TO GET THEIR WAY.
DO ANYTHING IN THEIR POWER TO
STOP THE CONSERVATIVE MAJORITY
FROM ISSUING A RULING ON A
PENDING CASE.
THIS LEAKER IS GOING TO BE
SORELY DISAPPOINTE